everyone this is Steve watch off with
Collider and I am here with the people
behind el Chicano how are you guys doing
great good how you doing dude I'm doing
excellent I super appreciate you guys
coming in studio super appreciate these
wonderful graphics that you've got up
here dude we're very excited about this
it's very funny images yeah you guys
have been fried together for an awfully
long time yeah so talk about when did
you guys first meet and do you remember
what it was told the greatest story we
have to tell the story now for this
interview so I was this was years ago
and I was doing I think this was pre I
think I was about to start shooting narc
and I had written pride and glory with
gavin o'connor and we were at a place
called shia off of Robertson Boulevard
and and I'm there and I'm just gonna
name drop because this is literally who
we were with that night David O'Russell
Spike Jones Gavin O'Connor Ray Liotta
and myself
I think Jason Patrick might have been
there I'm not sure but it was it was it
was a very heady mix of motley crew of
folks and I see this guy and and he's
really acting really intense and he's
got this young kind of pixie ish you
know woman with him and but he just
comes like that dudes like dark what's
going on and they go oh that's David O
Russell's friend Ben he's a split
personality by day he's a stuntman a
fighter by night he he'll he'll his
personality will switch and he'll become
this racist white guy that wears an
ascot and tours Beverly Hills looking at
real estate and they're doing a
documentary about him and I go that's
the craziest [ __ ] I've ever heard so so
so I see him we're talking he comes over
the table again very kind of dour very
solemn guy and he goes yeah man you know
it's hard to deal with it's hard to work
this career and and and his wife at the
time this woman named Christine says uh
she's like in this really kind of pixie
place she's totally and ah she goes I
never know when he's gonna change right
so so cut to oh boy we go to the bar and
cuz ray Liotta's like I don't believe it
so I go to the bar and Gavin goes oh no
no dude it's like a it's like a satire
David's got this this this buddy of his
stuff
and there this is all pretend they're
doing a documentary which they wound up
cutting together which is hysterical
which no one has ever seen I've seen it
it's dynamite
so that's how we met and and then about
ten months later we I was I was gonna do
ticker the BMW short film and I needed a
bad guy and I was looking at all these
pictures of stuntman because he had to
hang my helicopter and you know and I
see Ben they go that's the guy that's
been Hernandez that's the guy that I met
that he's a split personality
so he came down our si where we were
casting and we hit it off and we've been
best chums ever since ever since it's
awesome that's by the way crazy it is
that the crazy story it's a true story
well first of all a great story I mean I
would you would think that you would
find a way to release this whether or
not you know even online you know yeah I
think it was just you know it with the
agents involved and it was just before
the reality TV thing had started he did
have a screening at Raleigh studios I do
remember that too funny movie it's it's
really funny just kind of put a hold on
it and you know the I think I think his
team just had other other things well
they're also there's six scenes in there
were like he's got like like the wife
and then the girlfriend then what the
girlfriends got like a puma logo over
her face cuz it's cuz she's like she
wants they're being sponsored her and
then the wife once a while I want to
deed us so there's a floating adidas
logo over her family it's not six it's
really smart Wahlberg's in it ice cubes
and it was it was nuts yeah it was my
acting school it was fantastic if
anything you know and uh not happen at
least yeah I got that turned me into
thespian so that was good and I ant
through through David I met Joe I was
gonna say that if anything comes out of
this interview it'll be me seeing this
movie evangelizing this movie yeah there
it is so the reason you guys are coming
in today is your new movie for people
that have not seen the trailer then are
unfamiliar with it how have you been
telling it to friends how have you been
selling this thing I mean I think it's
you know listen it's kind of and Ben and
I kind of consciously did this we had
never kind of you know in terms of like
it basically starts out like a police
procedure like narc
and becomes kind of a superhero origin
film it's a guy kind of as he he's kind
of confronted with this evidence that
his brother it was someone who he
thought who basically his brother wasn't
what he thought he was he thought his
brother was a low-level kind of thug and
and on this kind of Odyssey through this
he gains his total understanding so it's
it's very about his brother so it's very
much it's oddly family oriented but it's
but it's kind of this again superhero
film slash cop movie it's it's kind of a
it's a bit of a platypus but it works
beautifully and it feels very in at
least for us it felt very unique the way
that we told the story well if I'm not
mistaken this idea germinated like 10
years ago with you with your with
because of your brother yeah you know is
it's it's been over 12 years now
I lost my youngest brother to gang
violence so you know the kind of
therapeutic therapeutical to get through
it and after talking to Joe I started
writing a memoir about his life and how
I dealt with it how my mother how my
brothers sisters dealt with it and and
it started coming up with ideas and
creating into script form and one of the
things that was one of the things that
was heavy for me was I always wondered
if my mother my grandmother it was the
one that raised us all I was wondering
if my dad was around maybe he'd still be
here yet you know have had that father
figure in his life and that's how the El
Chicano theme the soup real theme came
about is this metaphor of not having a
dad and continue to ride it throughout
the years building relationship with Joe
working with Joe unfortunately about
four years ago my wife and I we lost a
daughter and which was really heavy yeah
obviously and taking care of my family
and Joby and my best friend came he came
to me and said listen it's crazy as it
sounds you know you've dedicated this
this this story idea to your brother
maybe it's time to also dedicate it to
your daughter and finish it good bad
ugly just finish it so after taking care
of my family I had a friend Greg who had
a place in the financial district in New
York and I went away for four weeks in
the
and I wrote 185 pages good bad ugly to
put everything down it was tough it was
tough but I got it done thinking about
my daughter and thinking about my
brother and got back to LA Joe had a
place in Palm Springs just outside of
Palm Springs and in the course of a few
months back and forth with Joe's
incredible great knowledge as a writer
we pulled what was relevant and what
what the story need to be told and we
hug we cried tequila shots the whole
thing we got 125 pages and we had what
we thought was something really really
special and what's crazy about all this
even during I didn't mention this
earlier was was during the prep of it
and one of my biggest fans is my mother
who unfortunately she suddenly passed
away while we're prepping the film on
our first day of shooting was on her
birthday on her birthday here so it's
crazy just and ever each one of those
characters is someone that's related to
my life my childhood where I grew up in
the neighborhood and my wife always says
there's angels around this movie they're
angels around this film and it's like
you know which I love because I'm not
necessarily a big believer and I'm a
believer in spirituality but I don't
know you know we know we don't know
what's out there and and I don't want to
be a cynic or a pessimist about those
things but I do believe that there's
some karmically good things in this
movie and I think what had been in
Mensch is like you know I didn't know
what to do in the face of kind of this
this these types of tragedies other than
to kind of because you don't know what
balm will kind of heal whatever psychic
wounds those create and it's you know
it's inconceivable you should have to go
through what he went through but to
reconstitute that pain into something
like this into something that you could
artistically kind of pour yourself into
seem to be the only thing available to
us you know what I mean like let's just
go try to make this movie and that
kicked off you know three-year Odyssey
you know here we are
I'm curiously you guys you finished the
script and you're happy mm-hmm how tough
was it for you guys to land financing
how'd that whole thing come together
well we everyone said no even even
though we even though was the kind of
universe agreed the script was really
good and really interesting and there
was certainly something there lacking
what one studio flack called a Caucasian
influence we couldn't really they didn't
see them
marketability of this film so you know
like like any stubborn idiot and and the
you know the Celtic me the Irishman and
me gets my back of it goes well you know
I'm gonna show you I also and by oh it
was a terrible student in high school
and math being my my least favorite
subject
I could still look at the numbers and go
you've got an asian-american population
that purchase seven percent of the
tickets you've got an african-american
population pretty that purchases ten
percent of tickets give a Latin a Latino
Latin X Hispanic population that that
purchases almost twenty five percent of
the tickets on a genre film like this
it's closer to fifty
so I with those numbers I just think you
guys are missing something essential
here and so that said when they said no
we are friends up in Calgary who'd
become close with who were oil and gas
guys who wanted to get into the movie
business
we gave the script a bunch of caucasian
hockey fans embrace this latin-themed
superhero film like nobody's business
and literally got us everything we
needed to the point where once we were
done and the movie was great we all
loved it who had backed these same
people and they still said no so then it
was like well listen we're just gonna do
this ourselves and Tom Warren Burke
who's a dear friend of mine this is the
fourth film II and I've done together is
the only studio head to everyone Best
Picture Oscars at two different shops he
won for crash and Lionsgate in 2006 he
won for spotlight 2016 with open road he
got it and I thought once he got it and
I think Ben and I were both hugely
relieved we had learns of the bottom
ensure it was a dear friend of ours who
kind of came in and kind of graced it
and blessed it with his with his his
okay which is huge and then we just you
know and it's been we just we just keep
pushing through and and you know it was
something that we neither one of us were
gonna be content to kind of go alice's
call it a day we gotta go walter mcaddy
it's like in the eye of the needle man
you go all the way through you know well
i mean listen
the fact is and we these words get said
all the time but it's so true
representation matters and the fact is
you're making something that has not
been done before for an audience that
loves movies yeah yes and i think we you
know we heard this like why are you
worried about the the stereotypes you
know the
of the Hispanic characters listening
when you made a decision to make a 99.9%
Latino cast right who plays the good guy
who plays the bad guy is immaterial in
my mind the statement is much stronger
much more of a milestone than any of
that other crap and my response is well
Hans Gruber and John McClane were white
guys but nobody says you know what I
mean it's like whether the European
white guys play the bad guy the Americas
but yeah I think that these things exist
to kind of again to constantly rather
than there be the sense of a communal
sense of light and that's one of the
themes in the film this idea what it
means to be American mexican-american
you know whomever you are there's a
quote a Diego reads an FDR quote about
never forget that we are all of us
especially you and I descended from
revolutionists and immigrants and it's
that's a really powerful thing in the
movie this especially now what's going
on with this country in this kind of
constant division these were themes that
Ben and I were toying with before nee
this stuff happened before the the
plague that is Donald Trump kind of
descended on this on this fair country
so yeah man it's that that inclusive
nature and this and I don't I don't you
know we'd screen you know we screen to
Palm Springs for a crowd that was
probably the median age range of 75
almost all Caucasian they loved the feel
of the movie it didn't matter they
weren't going all these brown faces I'm
confused they loved the film because of
what the film was it was relatable and
the symmetry they recognized so that so
uh that's what has to a list a kid in
Russia or a guy in Tokyo should enjoy
all Chicano as much as a kid from East
lows well enjoy el Chicano you know talk
a little bit about how the film in the
editing room is ultimately a final
rewrite talk a little bit about how the
film changed in the editing room what
you learned from any early screenings
you know it's it's it's funny and I
learned that from Joe and in and the
time that I put in the business to it's
like you you you write it you write a
certain movie you added a certain yeah
yeah you shoot a certain movie you're
right you're shooting you had it all
different there was a process that we
went through we had what we thought was
gonna be the final cut that was about 14
minutes too long and it was tough it was
tough because everything everything's
personal to me in that film every every
nerrit
every storyline that we put in there
every character but there was a moment
Joe was talking about it earlier where
we were where we had screen the film and
we had we kept hearing the same refrain
it's ten minutes too long it was too
long yeah and listen minh portion man
there's a producer portion and the
proofs portion may ultimately stick up
for the director and go if this is the
version he wants this is the version
we're gonna do but i'd said to him
brother
listen you may not like what the
audience has to say but they're never
wrong right so let's take this into
account and and so separately when I was
in Atlanta prepping boss level III
rented out the Savannah College of Art
and Design it's really beautiful theater
they had there and we invited about 150
people and 140 of them because I had I
made out like a little mock like an NRG
kind of mock screening questionnaire 140
of them said the movies too long at the
beginning so once I presented this to
Ben it was like he's like all right we
gotta do we got to do and and so we took
out those you know they said 10 we don't
have taken out 14 and it made all the
difference in the world but we had to
lose stuff like you know this great
graveyard scene it that with Marleen 40s
it was bright my favorite character of
the film the mother and and and Frankie
quinones who's this really kind of bust
out up-and-coming comedian who plays was
it's great there's a troll outfit he
plays all these characters but creepers
probably his is it what he's most known
for we had to take Frank out of the
movie which is heartbreaking but again
these are the kinds of things he now
we're trying to make the most
commercially viable movie in this space
knowing what was already stacked against
us which is people don't believe in this
film or the studio hierarchy and the
studio structure doesn't believe in this
film so we had to kind of beat them at
their own game
sure does this mean that when it comes
out eventually on home video like a
blu-ray are you gonna do like an
extended cut of course 10 years from now
you could show the students the
director's cut of you know as much as
you know I always say the grace it was a
225 minute you know mediation on life
and death with occasional wolf attacks
it became an hour and 45 minute will for
tackle the occasional mediations on life
and death and switch the polarity of it
completely it's not dissimilar but I
wish
had that old version I don't we have the
extended version I can show theatrically
sure what happened with that extended
version of the Greg who knows it got
lost to the you know got lost his listen
it was it added expense to have this
extended version which we couldn't
afford because we're against we're
paying for everything ourselves but it's
worth but now I'm so glad that we have
it because it exists and it's something
that I think is really cool it just is a
artifact of that film you know there's
it's 14 minutes longer so it's I love
people eventually you know if this movie
works out it's the hit we all want it to
be that with that it that that version
will kind of gain notoriety and people
and they want to see it completely so
was that the main thing that was cut was
those fourteen minutes oh yeah yeah yeah
and then and then to Ben's credit again
this is like where we you know we didn't
have let's say this I don't want to go
bad in the Calgary film industry they we
didn't have what I would call the a crew
up and up in Calgary and we had some
guys come in Vancouver we had we had it
we had our Ben's stunt guys who are AAA
plus and we had some people that we
really trusted but we didn't have the
best kind of effects guys of it so we
had a couple of gags had gone sideways
on us and then including the last gag of
the film which was supposed to basically
end oh this suburban in this big duel
between El Chicano and shotgun dead the
David Castaneda character and it went
bad and Ben turned to me at 4:00 in the
morning and said can we go back to LA
back to LA because of the grit and the
kind of it gonna gut it out and he knew
I don't have the ending in my movie Ben
went assembled this really tight small
unit of guys they went out and shot a
alternate ending to when we originally
written and I defy you to ever think
that the movie wasn't intended to be
exactly that way but it wasn't it was
the classic lemonade from lemons
situation but this is just the stuff
that and heat why did we wind up doing
that for like eight grand yeah running
around stealing stuff you know which I
don't advocate I'm staring these cameras
don't do that don't do that stomach no
but we you know we had to we had to do
we had to do because we didn't have by
the way we didn't have the support of
the studios we didn't have that kind of
fallback that you know you're working
without a wire completely
I think a lot of people aren't gonna
realize that you have done stunt work on
I think basically every movie in the
last 20 years under selling this it's I
mean you've worked on everything it's
pretty crazy and you tend to forget I
got a my 11 year old Julian he was just
he's at that age now he's on the kid
knows how to run a computer better than
I do
search and find everything he went on
IMDB the other nine he's like dad you
got like 200 credits bro he's like yeah
yeah he's like you were in this and
you're in this it's like trying goes by
so fast I mean it's it's been a blessing
and it's it's you know when you're
passionate about something and being
part of this industry especially for I
where I came from its I'm very thankful
yeah man it's it's it's wild it's been a
while right name you again like people
should look up on IMDB on your resume
because it's crazy what can you share a
stunt or two that you you just can't
believe that you did I can't believe
that I did and then I did it again after
I hurt myself is uh there's it's when it
comes up that I always talk about it
kind of made a name for myself too was
on swordfish with with Travolta and I
don't know if I told you that it was it
was it was it was the opening sequence
there's about 30 SWAT guys coming in as
as Travolta's having a moment with God
he worked on ticker with you an
african-american actor Haysbert Dennis
Haysbert no no Oh Don Cheadle Don
cheetah and he's walking he's walking
out and this thing and they've did the
moat they did the wraparound they did
the wraparound a matrix shot and I was
one of the guys that's getting blown
through inside the coffee house and we'd
shot this up in Ventura County and so
they were individualizing the shots I
had to do this I was like a 35-foot
ratchet I mean the window was probably
about the size of the screen and there
was a concrete awning on the bottom and
the top so I had to really hit it I
didn't hit it it was like 250 psi it hit
me in the back just below the neck think
the car
beyond it came down sent both my legs
back to my calves onto the concrete
boom they started to swell up like like
Cornish hens they're like they're
growing and God forgive me the director
came up to me
Dominic Santa was Adamas instead of came
up and said we didn't get it can you do
it again and that was like I could even
move so they literally picked me up
stunt guy name of Frank Lloyd from from
our is a group put these put some shins
some hard plastic shins backwards on my
calves just in case if I were to hit it
again got back into the mark we started
rolling three two one action same
[ __ ] thing
Oh up the our knee came down went to the
hospital Ventura County I was out I was
out for about three months that's that's
what I can remember the most but it's
you know it's it's the nature of the
game and you kind of use that it's like
you know it's the toughness and the
rigor and just kind of you know it's
it's awareness right you know go big or
go home lose the attitude and I've
always I put that in reference to
learning how to write because of Joe and
directing it's it's been something I've
always adapted to everything I'm doing
what's funny really quick series at what
Ben always says to me is like it's
actually safer and cheaper now to do big
stunts
oh yes and it's ever been but people
just want CGI they don't want to do the
work but it's so safe and it's so easy
now to do not easy but I mean you know
yeah but comparatively is that what
here's what like computers and
everything oh yeah I mean this rigging
and and and you know harnesses and
harnesses you know it's it's it's state
state state of the art but they don't
want to do it yeah it always looks
better when it's broken oh sprockie
everything is practie yeah that's crappy
I believe I could be wrong that you've
directed some CW shows I have like arrow
Supergirl
legends of tomorrow yes few quick
questions because I don't know the
individual episodes oh god was bebo in
your episode of legends of tomorrow the
blue creature yes it was okay well then
you won
it's my favorite character on that show
everybody loves that character yes and I
wasn't told about it until literally the
day before and yeah it was yeah God yeah
it was the the hospital scene that they
had they had in it but it's a huge
following man that's a huge fonts and
those shows are great brilliant he's
been really good to me it's been a
fantastic training ground as a director
thanks to Joe the the initial my
director directorial debut was on state
of affairs that that that Joe had
created with Katie Heigl and then they
put me on the map and in Berlin he had
seen the episode or really dug in and
and all of a sudden I'm in the superhero
realm of directing all these crazy shows
which has been a blast well one of the
things for people that don't watch arrow
one of the things that I'm constantly
impressed with on that show is the level
of stunts every week what they're
willing to do they really raise the bar
and it's it's just a reminder that the
industry does not do enough to commend
stunt water God we agree on movies and
television so I'm just curious with
something like that with with the arrow
shows there's always a few action set
pieces on those on those shows talk a
little bit about directing because you
obviously have a history with stunts and
with second unit what was it like being
involved in that kind of stuff it's
amazing you know it's it's they've come
they're a Canadian stuntmen and the
whole ng show theirs is developed so
much in the past ten years they're
fantastic I mean you get there and we're
in a tone meeting we're prepping there's
one specific guy I have to say is James
Bamford they call him Bam Bam who which
I'm really happy that he's doing what
he's doing he started off doubling Steve
Amell on the show for arrow and has now
produced a director on the show and to
give and this idea that stunts court has
stuntman second of directors have a
vision that can tell stories he's been
doing it and he's done the finales for
the past I think three and a half almost
four seasons now but they got it locked
down
they've got a whole specific training
error for the actors they'll put dill
Dupree vaz they put things together
there on the spot and you know you've
got 78 days of prep that's it
and and Joe's experienced that too with
with our our guys here in Los Angeles
but they've got it down to a tee now
it's fantastic to watch I mean you
literally will sit down during him
during a prep meeting in production and
you'll talk about your ideas
you want this guy rats out the door
it'll be a one-er it'll be 12 guys
getting out of windows one kind of fire
burn and they're literally within 24
hours have it all put tomatoes in you
it's crazy it's goodbye no and no award
no Emmy for stunts it's snow no Oscar
for stone let's discuss to eat me he's
disgusting I completely agree and I
think that what Tom Cruise did for
example in the last mission impossible
he's ridiculous on the motorcycle I'll
tell you like again Ben tell this is
this is something you know people don't
talk about it used to be like it was
used to be Joey box was Tom's guy he
would go and test all those things and
I'm not taking anything away from crews
turn that guy's fearless but there is a
absolute complex system of checks and
balances and guys doing that before Tom
ever sets four hundred percent yeah
absolutely on the birds remember that
the great thing on the Brad Bird wanted
on the building it's amazing stuff
listen you know I completely agree and
all the people involved in these stunts
should be having like laser focus on
them because they make what they make
movies what movies are you know in their
life you know listen the only reason I
give Tom so much credit is I don't see
any other oh no he's amazing he's got
he's got he's got the wave of titanium I
could never do what he does no not even
I don't even know I mean it's it's not a
raised hand you know hopefully hopefully
even with this platform with this film
as a director be recognizing what my
background is that maybe you know you
know it'll it'll kind of awake the
industry up and go if you're giving them
two special effects and two makeup and
wardrobe
why aren't we and it's recording I
completely agree publican I think that
the that you know the star system the
movie started the court doesn't want
people to kind of see behind the curtain
that much you know what I mean and and
to really realize wow these guys are
doing a lot of rigging a lot of testing
and a lot of kind of
fool proofing of stuff and making things
airtight so that guys like you know Tom
Cruise can can are safe ultimately safe
let's also be honest how many times are
we shining a light on second unit
directors yeah in what they do and like
I for example like I love guy Norris and
what he's done but like no one knows who
got Norris it right like because the no
one want crane there Simon you know no
one I mean listen it's like everyone
wants to believe that it's the one
director that does everything but the
fact is yeah it's the director's vision
but there's a lot of effing people sure
that are bringing that vision to life
and there's also listen I think like you
know what at least Ben and I went Ben
and I work together I thought we had a
we had a wonderful symmetry and like you
know on smokin aces around the eighteen
and that was all Ben's stuff you know
there was a lot of that stuff that I
didn't show he and I conceptualized but
we would we you know he'd have to go out
and do his thing I have to go do my
thing and it's like I think there are
listen I certainly think a guy like Dan
Bradley doesn't work as well at anybody
like green grass like that's that's his
standout stuff I certainly think that
it's also the collective arrangement
between director and seconder director
that and he won inspires the other
completely me I'll give an example I was
on the set of the Avengers with Joss
Whedon and I'm on one stage it's just
directing the actors talking and the
drama stuff and the scenes then we went
over to another stage and the second
unit is filming this massive action set
piece it's not Joss no no no no he's
working with the key dialogue no I think
it's and you're literally handing I
remember like you know you're handing
storyboards over and going okay this is
what we want to shoot and and when you
get guys again as good as Ben and as and
as talented you get this you get this
great stuff you get these these
tremendous kind of sequences that that
that are born of again but also he
understands my taste I understand his
takes I did second year for him on El
Chicano so you know myself and Frank
Torres but there was again Frank saw
frigging with him on first unit I got to
go direct second unit so that's the
that's the give and take and that's the
ebb and flow of the stuff you know
something else I want to address is you
are in post or you're almost done with
boss love done which is I'm so excited
to see this thing yeah what can you do
for people that don't know what the
movie is about
what do you say I can say it's basically
like you know Groundhog Day and diehard
had a child it's you know listen it's
it's kind of you know Smith was like
source code the Gyllenhaal thing or like
edge of tomorrow it's really not because
you know this version of the
quote-unquote you know the repeating day
like the kind of the endless death loop
day it's not somebody who oh my god
what's happening me it's somebody who
it's had to happen to 140 times when you
meet Frank grillers character the
beginning he's already bored stiff with
what's going on to the point where he
just goes to the same restaurant every
day and gets drunk and ways to get
killed and so that's kind of the point
of departure for boss level and and I
could say Hannah Hart and Ben has seen
it I don't think that I've done with all
due respect to the gray and I'll do
respect to narc and so on I don't I
think this is the best film I've done
it's fantastic because it's it's the it
is the embodiment you know what is it's
like somewhere between the gray and
smokin aces only with no cynicism
whatsoever it's very much me softening
in my old age I think but it's but it's
I think it's a wand meows pros who shot
el Chicano friends shot bostonia our
dear friend the DP said the best quote
about it I heard about ball so it's
funny as hell until it's not and then
it's even better so I think that's a
wonderful way of looking at the film for
for people that when are people gonna
see this thing you know what I'm having
a big two days before el Chicano opens
I'm having a huge refers recruited
screening so I will report back thusly
about where we're gonna be and what
we're gonna be doing how I last time I
spoke to Frank was maybe for real man
yeah other stuff what's coming up for
war party in terms of what you guys are
working
we're got we've got the raid the remake
of the raid which we hope we start
talking about this for at least yeah
five or six days yeah that's gonna be
exactly that's gonna be something that
we're hopefully we're gonna be in prep
the next in the next hopefully the next
few weeks actually well I say that and
then you never know because it's it's
moviemaking so it's it's talked about
this for real like three years sometimes
the finials don't blow
like you wanted right you know so so
that's it looks like it's next May this
thing called wildfire which is great
it's kind of female kind of female first
blood and the lead character only says
one word the whole movie which I'm
pretty excited about is great I won't
ruin you what the word is but she says
one word I'm gonna say [ __ ] no I wish
and then I did this thing I wrote the
spec called thorn which I'm really
really fired up about which I will
hopefully do right after the raid maybe
as soon as the end of the year maybe the
top of 2020 with the raid and then
they'll Chicano sequel that's right yeah
of course yeah with the raid how how
you've been in pre-production on this if
you will for a while how has it changed
during the process and what is the
version that you are looking forward to
for people to see I think the version
that we have again Gareth was wonderful
about kind of communicating to Frank and
I list I don't want you you know you
guys do your version I'm excited to see
whatever you guys are gonna do with it
and I also think that listen you know
smokin aces is not dissimilar from the
rain that came out six years earlier
about guys attacking you know a
structure and trying to remove a guy
from the penthouse that's kind of so I
was like this is ultimately kind of
familiar territory but I think where we
differ is you meet Frank's character
having just rotated back from a really
really brutal operation like Special
Forces and he's got you know soft tissue
damage his hands and his rotator cuff is
blown out he's got you know they take
fluid off of lives left knee and fluid
off his right knee and the doctors
basically tell him listen you're toying
with the real that you're at the razor's
edge of PTSD and you need three months
of just nothing R&R because you're beer
beer jacked up and in that space he gets
the message that his brother we thought
had been dead for four years is actually
alive and working for a very bad guy in
Caracas and in 18 hours they're gonna
kill his brother
these forces are gonna descend and
murder the bad guy and murder the
brothers so do you want to go and get
your brother who you think who you
thought is dead and do you want that
opportunity so that's the that's the
that's the where we start
that's an awesome start yeah the my
other my last thing on the raid is and I
think I've asked you this in the
but it's it's so true the raid the
action set-pieces in that movie are so
ridiculous
they're they're insane yeah they
accomplished yeah with I don't want to
talk about how they accomplished ability
it's crazy how they what they did use it
literally using dead bodies in Jakarta
to do some yeah
it's crazy what they did yeah but
there's gonna be that comparison in
terms of whatever you do there's gonna
be a comparison to the action of that
raid the action your yeah what we're not
I asked me to describe what we're gonna
do
action wise I say I want it I want the
entire movie to feel like the knife
fight between Adam Goldberg and the
German in Saving Private Ryan everything
like the whole Aldi all that stuff to
feel that because what I do think that
will differ this from is that there has
to be in every I think great action film
there's always an emotional quotient
that you're dealing with there's always
you know if John McClane isn't walking
over glass with bare feet and you know
that his wife's there and you know he's
got a dog you don't really care as much
as you know you really want that guy to
win because you know it's at stake
try you have to have a sense of stakes
and I think I talked about this and I
was talking a friend of mice you know
for all of the the the tremendous excess
of those last two Matrix films which I
enjoyed the hell out of them they never
kind of got to the to the great tension
of just canneries trying to answer a
phone at the end of the movie you know
what I mean like there was great paid
those those great kind of sense about oh
god he's is he gonna make is gonna make
it and I think we get the spectacle of
it I think becomes outweighs what's
really the heart and soul of it and I
think that's what you have to remember
is that you gotta have that attached you
know it's the comparison I talk about
between Lord of the Rings in The Hobbit
Lord of the Rings is about the end of
the world it is literally the
annihilation of everything the Hobbit is
these people just wanting to get gold
right there you know or in John wick you
know the what happens with the dog the
rest of the movie I am rooting for you
know Keanu to destroy people yeah yeah
you know like we're absolutely out what
happened in the best of those revenge
kind of genre films you have that
inherent like you want it to happen
because because you need this you know
we
that catharsis it's the same thing in
any I said in any good action movie that
you'll see you'll find that commonality
completely I'm going to stop there
because I'm basically out of time but
wait what's going on with did you
mention Point Blank I did no we're done
what's the story it's a job we it is a
how do I describe it it is a kind of a
tease homage buddy action movie deck a
48 hours like a 48 hours kind of with
very much an 80s tinged kind of
sensibility about it that we're
extremely happy about and and and I
think Joe Lynch shot the hell out of
that movie and want me shot the hell out
of that movie and and we've been and
it's been a lot of fun and and and Frank
and Anthony Mackie have such easy
immediate chemistry with one another
that it's really it's great movies
really really good I'm excited for
people to see it I think it's a Netflix
in July believe yeah I listen I could
ask you a million other questions but I
just want to say to both of you Congrats
on getting this movie made thank you
both so much for coming in horse and I
really appreciate it of course all right
we appreciate it thanks so much brother
thanks bro